there are three main ways to Market your
business first one I called the fast
passive Freedom it's you selling it's
you reaching out to people and you
offering your products and services the
goal is not just to sell them something
out of the gate but it's to hop on a
call to give them value so then it's a
question how do you find the people who
are potential ideal clients for you to
reach out to them and a lot of them are
posting on social media you find them
see what they're talking about Reach Out
offer to ask for help it's reaching out
and making a list of people who are
potential ideal clients this is one
thing where people get wrong it's not
just anybody especially in a service
based business at the beginning it has
to be somebody who can afford your
services so for reaching out to a bunch
of people who then can't afford US well
you can help them and you can give them
a lot of free content but if you're
doing Outreach we're trying to find
ideal clients who can afford our
services and that is a process that a
lot of people don't like to do because
it's sales but it's the fastest way to
grow your business but it's making a
list of the people who could be ideal
clients and then reaching out to them
it's LinkedIn it's Instagram it's
Twitter it's like wherever they're
living where are they spending their
time and it's sending a message like a
text message and then recording a quick
video of some ideas and then in the
office to hop on a call to help the
offering isn't like and by the way I
charge two thousand dollars a month uh
as a starting point but it's
it's an offer to hop on a call to help
and then once you're on a call with them
that's when you hopefully just give so
much value that then they ask hey how
can we work together if you ever hop on
a sales call it's really just giving
value
for 30 to 60 minutes and then at the end
of like how do we had like we want to do
more how do we work together how do we
do this together what's the next step
so that's that's the starting process
that's that's sales again as soon as you
can make money in your business the
easier it is to to just maintain the
momentum and gives you a lot more
opportunities to go off and build uh the
company that you want so that's the
first part
sales we make a list we're doing
Outreach and how fast you want to grow
is completely about how much work you
want to put in right again and build the
serve I'd say 50 to 100 messages a day
you could do that it's completely doable
but you have to be targeting the right
people who can afford to pay you and
you've got to be uh doing the Outreach
so that's sales and you don't even need
content I mean a lot of what we talk
about here is making content which is
great I'll dive into that but you know
if you need content for that you need a
little bit on your social like on your
Instagram or your Twitter your LinkedIn
or wherever you're going to be reaching
out to people you need to have a little
bit there if you're going to sales route
you don't need to make a ton of content
now these are not exclusive ideas you
can do both at the same time but that's
the fastest way to do it
so if your goal is hey I want to have a
six figure business by the end of this
year or next year this is the fastest
way to do it okay Outreach the second
one is through Partnerships
who are the people that if they knew who
you were would have a huge impact on
your business I just need this person
know about me like me trust me if they
did that then they could refer me to
five people ten people 20 people 100
people a thousand people a hundred
thousand people like who are the people
that if they knew you they do a lot of
the marketing the sales for you so in
the first model you're out there doing
Outreach one to one one to one one to
one one to one at scale right and the
second one is you're only targeting
certain select people and then they're
out marketing and talking about you
because they know you like you trust you
and maybe there's even incentive model
built in for them to earn a commission
in helping you the easiest way to do
that
this is actually not inbuilt to serve
for those who have the book the easiest
way to do that is to have a show and you
invite people on and we've talked about
this you know a couple weeks ago and
I'll I'll keep talking about it having
Biz Dev as an ongoing segment
or one of your shows on your channel I
think can tremendously help your
business
so in your content that you're putting
up it's not just your thought leadership
and not just your coaching and not just
you getting your ideas out to the world
but also an interview show that leads to
business development for you
right if you are if you're trying to
make an x amount goal that's that
matters to you right now like you want
to hit a hundred thousand or a goal or a
million or whatever like if it's
actually really really important to you
the thought leadership sharing your
message is how you change the world but
it's the slowest path and so so many
people quit along the way because they
run out of money
so this this is an order of like what's
going to generate
faster money for you
sales first right Outreach and then
having a show where it's Biz Dev
so who if they knew who you were would
have a meaningful impact on your
business and then invite them to be
interviewed for your show as much as I
send videos out to people I'm going to
send a whole bunch of videos out this
morning to a bunch of you right and and
people write back like oh thank you this
made my day like most people are still
not sending videos out so send videos
out like Instagram direct message video
makes a huge difference an eight second
video can dramatically change how
somebody sees you how they show up in
their day and you're staying top of mind
with them and if you've seen my videos
they're super like today was freezing
cold it's just above freezing here in
Toronto Canada I'm walking outside I got
my my my jacket on and my hoodie on and
like I'm freezing and just like very
basic messages like hey Nancy happy
Thursday super excited to see you Movie
Makers soon and I'm I'm thinking about
you on my believe walk today and it's
freezing here in Canada look at the
leaves though they're changing colors I
love you I'll see you soon believe send
right I don't know how long was that 12
seconds like but that means that makes a
difference
it makes a difference I think of Kira
who did the same thing to me right where
we did an Instagram live together we did
a book channeling hero was a guest a
couple months ago here Movie Makers if
you haven't seen it the replays are in
in the chat or in the in the Discord uh
and we ended up partnering together on
Freedom House her publishing company
that's also now mid-6 for your business
uh and so it's like getting somebody on
your show can lead to tremendous
opportunities
I did a YouTube boot camp webinar a week
or two ago and we had a guy on who
he had a couple hundred thousand
subscribers on the YouTube channel and
he was selling
helping people pass their driving test
in different states like how to pass a
driving test in New York how to pass the
driving test in Cincinnati
et cetera and that's a that's a
challenging Channel because
that's not one where people typically
would subscribe and watch ongoing
contents like I care about passing a
driving test and then I'm at I don't
want to continue for the next five years
watching driving test content right
and so he wants to Pivot his business to
sell instead of one to one to people how
to pass a driving test in Cincinnati
it's a one-to-one course to selling to
corporate and helping them helping
bigger corporations uh trucking
companies
with their training for defensive
driving for their trucks
like okay
amazing
so the next question becomes if you know
who you're targeting right cool who is a
decision maker at that company so
there's tons of companies that could
sell this stuff right this how many
trucking companies are there of the
world how many companies have a fleet of
trucks there's lots or just in America
there's lots so who are the companies
and then who's the one who's going to
hire you at that company
and he said the chief safety officer
perfect
you invite the chief safety officers
from all of these big companies on your
show as a guest
you are the only one who's ever asking
them for an interview like who's talking
to the chief safety officer and having
them as a guest on their podcast nobody
who wants to talk about safety nobody
right so nobody's ever reached out to
them it's not like you're trying to get
the rock on your Channel
is the chief safety officer at FedEx
right it's like they've never been asked
for an interview in their life so they
they're they're a lot more honored now
so it's it the decision maker who you're
trying to get in touch with who could be
a huge partner Source a referral source
for you
could be actually pretty easy to get to
because nobody's nobody's trying to get
to them from the media angle the
challenges people are going in thinking
Partnerships that person doesn't want to
sit down with you and have a partnership
talk
but they'd love to come on and be a
guest on your show
and talk safety or talk about whatever
the thing is that you guys are
offselling right and so that channel
doesn't have to be a giant Channel like
he could start a brand new channel and
said I'm starting a new channel on
YouTube talking about safety and how
important it is and I want I want people
to learn defensive driving and why
whatever you know whatever the stats are
whatever it means so much to him cool
I'm starting I'm starting a brand new
channel on this
do you want to be a guest on my show or
because I'm super curious about how
FedEx does defensive driving and your
safety record right
people will come on a brand new show
but they don't want to sit down and have
coffee with you to talk about
Partnerships
but when they come on your show they
fall in love with you
they get to know what you're all about
and then they want to do business with
you the opportunity for you to have
guests on your show to talk about their
thing
that you generally care about but their
potential clients of yours or referral
partners of yours
I think everybody should put some
serious like this could be the biggest
change that you make in your content in
the next six months to to dramatically
transform your business
on a revenue side
who are the people that knew who you
were make a list of 100 people that knew
who you were and again not Oprah and not
the rock the industry people who they
knew who you were would make a huge
impact on your business growing and then
do a weekly show inviting them as a
guest on that you can do through zoom
and just record just like this
and even if that's on a brand new
channel or part of your current Channel
that can lead to significant
relationships for you so that's the
second one and then the third one is
content and content is where we focus a
lot of energy here on like how do you
get your message out to the world and
what I love thinking about with content
just to frame it is what's the thing
that you're trying to sell and then show
me you doing it
um yesterday I had Dr Yeager on my
Instagram live He's The psychotherapist
for the Detroit Pistons
and he got he has a new book out he's
been on Oprah and and you know does a
lot of things behind the scenes for high
performance mostly around athletes but
now expanding and we did a little mini
coaching session
then we talked about me being shy and
and why you know and giving me some
advice and breaking that down
that's the best kind of content
if you are a psychotherapist the best
thing you can do is show me you breaking
somebody down
don't just tell a story about somebody
else and definitely don't just
um
give me the five ways to XYZ like show
me you coaching show me you helping
somebody
it's the easiest kind of content to make
and it leads to people wanting to work
with you
I want to talk about storytelling public
speaking and I want to I want to go
deeper with you guys today when I was
thinking about what to talk about for
today I thought you know what we should
go deep with the questions that you guys
have so think about the question you've
got what's the most important thing
you're struggling with right now with
storytelling or public speaking and
whether we'll do it in the text chat or
we bring people up on stage and talk
about it I really want to go deep to
make sure that you're getting value out
of this like how do we take this
speaking career of yours to The Next
Step storytelling and public speaking
where are you struggling right now
and your question will probably be
really valuable to everybody else
watching as well all right we got a
couple hands coming up so doctor uh
let's bring Dr o up
good morning I'm a Storyteller but I
haven't
honed it down so
my question is
how do I say one story stick with it to
have the call to action what I want
people to gain from it because I can
tell stories
but I haven't quite
figured out how to make it work for the
other person so the best stories that
you say from stage are the ones where
you are helping people first right like
the best stories that I've told are
because I help people one-on-one first
because when you're speaking live on
stage to a group of people you don't get
a lot of fantastic feedback like you can
kind of look at their faces and see
what's going on but they have a lot of
thoughts and and and yeah buts and what
ifs in their head but they're not
expressing them but when you sit down
with somebody one-on-one
you get the feedback
you get to see you get to see what
they're thinking you get to hear the
real thoughts going on in their head
and so my best stories have come the
stories that I tell on stage the stories
I just told in Vegas I've told countless
times to people one-on-one and I know
how to tell the story so that it moves
them to a result
you can have a million different stories
and it's awesome that you're a
Storyteller Stories the the point is to
get people to move towards some kind of
action so the key is figuring out which
story to tell in which context so if I'm
If You're Gonna Go on stage and speak
what's the end goal that you want to
have happen
and then what's the right Story to Tell
in this situation
does that make sense
I'm figuring it out
I would practice telling more stories to
more individual people
and ask them what they thought
gotcha and especially the resistance
like where does it not make sense
okay I'll tell you a quick story
okay
I had eye surgery
um
the end of last month
and when I went to my doctor's office he
said I could go back to work I work in
the ER and I decided I need a doctor's
note
not to work till July so that I can sit
with what I really want to do which is
in this space
and so
the story for me is I have no income
so I have to figure
if I really want to be in this space or
not because just the way to help people
is to be able to be consistent and to
have a way to pay my bills otherwise I'm
not going to be in this space I'll go
back because every time I'm in the year
I can't I can't fit into this space it's
a different Zone
so the story for me is to tell people
that are 60 years old in healthcare that
they need to live their best life
even though they've lived a best a
better life in something they know it's
okay to Pivot
because if you don't
what are you going to do at the end of
life
and so I mean that that's I mean that's
why I did it that's the story I told
myself
and so I'm just trying to figure
how to take life situations and make it
stories to help people
make decisions and I made that decision
to say I burned that bridge is it a
permanent bridge I think it is
but I have to make it work
that's why I came on the call
no I love it and
your your journey
becomes the story so a couple things in
there right like you haven't done the
thing yet right you haven't built the
successful career outside of healthcare
yet no so we can't say here's what I've
done you know look at what I've done
but
the story is that you have the courage
to try
and the willingness to try
and you're going to make mistakes and
you're going to have self-doubt and
you're going to not be sure if it's
working out or not
and the willingness to try is the
inspiration
so
if if we're telling a story
if my main call Action was I want people
to be willing to try like if that's the
message be willing to try to try right
you can have tons of stories but my
takeaway from this one is hey be willing
to try
so when our people are around you or
they hear your speech or they watch your
video I need to feel like I I should go
off I've got an idea I need to be
willing to try if Dr O's going to go off
and do it and and I need to be willing
to try as well
so the message is be willing to try then
you can tell a story around it
gotcha let me tell you guys I I'm I'm
here trying to I'm trying to do it too
like I haven't started living my life
yet I'm trying I don't know all the
steps I'm trying to figure it out I know
that I don't want to see any ER anymore
because it makes me feel X like whatever
it actually makes you feel
and I know I want to be in a different
spot and I'm tired of of people telling
me that I'm too old
and I'm tired of telling myself that I'm
told and that I can't change
and then whatever whatever like the
actual thoughts are in your head that
when you wake up because you don't wake
up every day and like I'm gonna go crush
this goal it's like what what are the
actual thoughts in your head because
that's what brings us in and makes it
personal okay
and then you share and I'm I still get
up every day because I'm willing to try
and I want to make this happen
so that when I walk away I've been
inspired by the story
but my takeaway is be willing to try
gotcha thank you very much now when
you're talking to somebody one-on-one
then you can ask for feedback okay so
what are you gonna do now
and you see where this are they actually
off ready to try something or are they
still dealing with their own doubts and
insecurities
because when you're speaking on stage
again you're speaking to a a group of
people you don't get that feedback
but if you can if you can structure you
have so many stories to tell cool they
don't all have to fit into one video or
one speech
one main message per video per speech
that when I walk away with if you think
like the advantages came back from in
Vegas
it's like it was three days four days I
don't remember so many speakers
everybody gets up there's another speech
another speech that's like it's speech
overload like you guys have all been to
events and it's just crazy speech
overload so to to
hope that somebody remembers everything
that you're going to say is impossible
so it's like what's the one thing that
I'm going to get from your message
that I can take away that you are you
are the most valuable person for me from
that event
and it's such that you having that
intention as opposed to just standing up
saying I've got a bunch of stories to
tell
gotcha good luck all right Milko in the
house I saw him bouncing what do we got
Milko my question it's not very well
formed uh but
for me because from what I know a good
storytelling you need to show emotions
and it's kind of like last time we kind
of covered this and you showed us how
you actually took your 700 videos or
what was them or something like that to
find your uh self and be yourself on
camera so for me because I usually I'm
not used to sharing my emotions in any
way so I usually uh I'm usually quite
intense when I coach people but I don't
share my emotions and I know that for
example for storytelling when you show
your emotions when you share them uh
it's much better and people can relate
to you more so I'm trying to
find this voice but I can't really make
the difference because sometimes I I
feel like I'm really putting it there
and I'm kind of showing my emotions and
stuff like that and then it turns out
the video that it's not uh or someone
else is telling me that it's not really
it sounds a bit a bit uh not genuine and
so on so so kind of I'm not sure where
I'm going with this but you know
so listen I mean if you if you go back
and watch our session from a couple
weeks ago is you know I I
self-criticized my videos or critique
them going back and and uh when I got
the feedback to have more motion you see
my very my very beginning videos that
the content was still almost still what
I talked about now
the delivery was way off it's like okay
guys so I got a question from my reader
and you know it's like it's just super
boring watching it back and then when I
got the feedback to try to do more
motion it felt forced right like as I
was critiquing my videos like look at
that video like I'm trying there is more
energy but it's not real Evan energy
it's a forced energy but it's it's
better than what it was but it's not
where it needs to be and it's still
pushing through that discomfort to uh
practice and work on it because it was
80 there some of the things are right
but I had to keep
I had to keep trying it on to like make
make it fit for me one of the best
things that helped me this advice I told
Alex too who's in the house so we could
talk about him
um when Alex first started doing stories
at TDS uh China van salsa he was he was
doing stories at the front of the class
he's doing stories on videos it all
sucked I mean like what we all suck at
the beginning right and Alex and Alex
and add to the chat if he wants kind of
sharing stuff but
um it was really bad and and the points
were still good but the delivery was
just really really bad
um and so the exercise I gave him was
whenever you feel the emotion film
so whenever you feel like that
Breakthrough video for me I figure what
number was like 670 something
um
was because I came back from that event
I was trying to help entrepreneur I was
so frustrated and so I I just filmed I
had no idea what I was gonna say and I
just filmed and the energy was on point
the content wasn't as good but the
energy was so much better
and it's the energy that's actually
going to carry the day and so whenever
you feel the emotion if if you just come
out of movement makers and you feel
grateful or you just come out of a
coaching call and you feel frustrated or
whatever has happened like you feel
emotions throughout your day
they just may not be there when you're
about to press record on the camera
so the trick is have your phone with you
which we probably all do and and when
you feel that emotion you film
and it does two things
one
it it gets you
the practice of speaking from your heart
because we're speaking from our head
with most of our videos so it gets you
the practice of speaking with your heart
and let it out express because you feel
what it feels like but you you haven't
practiced vocalizing what it feels like
and so it gets you that practice the
second thing is when you go to try to
tell that story again if you're gonna
then tell that story on stage you can
tell that story in a future video you
can go back and watch
how you delivered it when you were
actually in that state and then you can
think back to yeah that's how I felt
because it's hard to manufacture that
sometimes when you're just sitting at
home on your ball kind of bouncing
around figuring out you know talking
about food choices right
um so that's the best activity that I
would recommend it's like try to catch
it during the week and then film even if
you don't post it just try to catch an
emotion any uh a positive or negative
emotion
and film it and don't stress if it sucks
and don't stress if it's not well
thought out or
um you don't really know what you're
saying as you go but just practice that
because the more you practice that the
better you'll get at it and again you
can go watch it back and say yeah that's
what it feels like to to have that that
thought again so you could get out of
your head and into your heart
thank you so very helpful yeah I
remember one time where like when I was
really grinding on Alex to do this we're
at a uh we're at a dance event so we we
hosted these dance parties once a week
or so and um he was uh
uh he I forget he had some kind of
emotion right he was upset or he was
happy I don't remember what it was like
dude go film like now yeah go go film
now and and then he he filmed yeah it's
like that's what you need to train
yourself to do you're feeling emotional
film film even if just for yourself to
get the repetition down
foreign
makers in the house this is one of the
most fun topics because this is
something that I struggled probably the
most with in making my content and one
of the biggest reasons why uh I did not
do well at the beginning and so I don't
know who asked this topic but this is
this is a fantastic one we are talking
today about how to make content that
touches people's hearts so let's dive in
this is awesome we talk about emotional
commitment the thing I struggled the
most with and we're gonna go and look at
some of my old videos and be embarrassed
by how bad it was at the start uh so
just like your success can be other
people's inspiration
um how much you sucked and kept going
can also be other people's inspiration
so that's that that's the goal for
today's session so emotional commitment
I've never even heard of this term
before this is something one of the one
of the most important changes that I
made as a content creator that started
to make an impact and it came from my
agent Steve this is a picture of me and
Steve uh when we went up in New York and
my first videos
weren't that great and you can go back
and you can watch we're not going to go
through too many today but a few of the
more embarrassing ones and this is my
very first video and in my first video I
thought I had to be professional I
thought I had to be in a suit and sit
down and have it professionally filmed
and memorize my lines and be perfect and
scripted and this took two days to make
uh and I had three comments in that
first year right my mom my sister and
this guy ABC TV ads so in one year my
first video going up I only had three
comments and two of them were from my
family uh and so it was it was really
rough
um and I made all the mistakes that we
all make and so the goal was something
like this and movement makers is to try
to help you guys shortcut the path so
that you're not um you don't have to
take as long as I did to get there and
so emotional commitment behind the
content made a huge huge huge huge huge
difference so you you guys are you're
you know what you're talking about
you're experts right you've been through
something and that something can help
Inspire and serve a lot of people the
problem is and the problem for me and in
watching your videos the problem for you
is you're saying a lot of times the
right words and we're so focused on
saying the right words but there's no
emotion behind the words and if there's
no emotion behind the words then people
won't follow along they won't pay
attention they won't take notice they
won't do the action and your content
your channel won't grow so even more
important than the perfect words that
you're saying is how emotionally
connected are you to the thing that
you're saying it's the old Maya Angelou
quote the people remember how you made
them feel right that's what they
remember the most not what you said but
how you made them feel and if there's no
emotion behind the words you're saying
then they won't feel anything different
so
uh Steve had just incredible patience
with me for some reason he just loved me
for some reason I guess uh because it
took me a long time to get halfway
decent on camera on videos and um yeah I
must have been his little Pet Project or
charity case to help me get going so
emotional commitment is what we want to
start paying attention to in our content
all right deep breath let's start
looking at some old Evan Carmichael
videos and I will I will give myself
some coaching uh and look back so I
started in 2009
okay and and I don't we don't have to go
all the way back you guys can look at
that if you want this is 2011 now this
is my third year of making content okay
so it's not just like my first video
going up this is Evan in year three of
making content okay so first I'm making
all the classic mistakes right I have my
intro coming on as the first thing I
thought I had to be fancy and
professional and show off right so you
know we're not doing this no fancy
intros
all right
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Kevin in today's
video okay so already you know there's
no energy
hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan right I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers Ina Oro who is asking about
the videos that I make how I make them
and why I make them so specifically
wrote in asking hi Evan you're just a
great guy for being consistent with your
messages thank you I have two questions
for you one in what way do these
messages you send to people positively
impact your business I mean economically
or financially and two do you have
people working on them and sending them
out for you or do you have to write and
work on people's questions new ideas
continuously when do you have the core
of your business to take care of as well
I want to say something like this but I
need to know if it's worth my while
thanks and Oro so a couple of ideas here
for you on on how I create these videos
um most of the videos that I create come
from reader questions just like this
just like the one that that you wrote in
I don't make money from these videos
sometimes they're sponsored by a
corporate partner but most of the videos
are not sponsored I do
the videos because I really like helping
out entrepreneurs and this is what gets
me excited okay so thoughts what are
your thoughts on this video pop it pop
it in the chat love to see what's coming
up Chrissy says it's adorable Ida says
nice computer where's the computer oh
well this is 2011. that's an old school
computer uh is that Windows 95 I have no
idea uh how are you making money back
then so I I mean I wasn't at the
beginning right I had some some sponsors
on videos but like I said I just I love
doing it you know like I'm three years
in making content just because I love
doing it now I had I had sold my
business already a different business my
first company and I had some money so it
wasn't that I needed this to necessarily
pay off right away
um but I just love doing it right
they're like I'm how do you keep going
even on year three when you're
struggling and not getting traction and
not making any money well just because I
love actually doing it your smile is
underutilized no energy says Michael shy
Evan low energy compared to current
event it's it's somewhat flat that's
very kind Denise I'd say it's very flat
compare it to you now but still genuine
honest and real so this is this is the
difference right
uh Izumi says I don't feel Evan that I
feel now critiques monotone no energy no
powerful intro statement yeah so to
Denise's point right it's still genuine
honest and real this is where
this is where a lot of you are stuck and
I think honestly a lot of you are
already better than this
I'm still the same guy
and I still have the same a lot of same
information to share I mean I've
hopefully learned a little bit in the
past what 11 years but but
I'm still I know a lot at 2011 knows a
lot 2011 Evan 2011 Evan knows a lot and
you guys know a lot and you're already
better than me probably in this but this
is what a lot of people's videos look
like when they're getting into thought
leadership you like read somebody's
question and then you just start talking
and sharing and helping but because it's
flat and monotone people won't listen to
the actual content
and so I'm still the same guy this is
still me I have I have less hair but
more emotional commitment
that's the difference right so we don't
have to watch this whole thing we'll go
we'll go to the next one Zane says Evan
isn't bouncing bouncing helps
okay so
2012. we're a full year later now and
now also just quick update these are not
the old thumbnails I used I don't even
have thumbnails back then we've just
been going back and updating all of our
old thumbnails so let's see how good
2012 of an another year of practice four
years in now on my YouTube journey and
I'd love to see some comments down as
well as you start watching what do you
think
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my Facebook viewers Jasmine who wrote in
a really really long message it's almost
a page here of a message I won't read
the whole thing but the Crux of it is uh
I know in my heart and mind that it
takes money to make money how do you
make money if you don't have the finance
system to back it up and that's the key
thing I wanted to address today
I want to get that notion out of your
head it doesn't take money to make money
it's not about how many resources you
have it's about how resourceful you can
be so if you look at all the the famous
successful entrepreneurs especially in
the past a lot of them didn't come from
wealthy backgrounds a lot of them didn't
have huge investors they bootstrapped
their way up you know they they make the
tough decisions and did not go out and
spend a lot of money and the key here is
not spending until you're making money
okay so we don't have to watch the whole
thing quick thoughts better energy
better better lighting more comfortable
I'd say better you look more confident
more energy see more confident more
comfortable
uh still pitching in the beginning a
little more energy and you got right
into it yeah so I mean this is still I
think pretty bad if you if you're
comparing it to 2011 Evan then maybe
it's a little bit better but in terms of
emotional commitment
it still sucks there's still there's
still no real energy behind this I'm
just answering the question and again I
just didn't know this is just part of if
I knew and I had something to work on I
could make it better I thought here's
this person's question I'm going to
answer the question and and hopefully it
helps and move on to the next thing and
so there you know I might be a little
more practiced or comfortable in front
of the camera with an extra year under
my belt but in terms of the emotional
commitment behind the words it's not
really there and it's funny that you
know I'm watching back this is now 10
years ago that that whole line that I
used about it's about how resourceful
you are instead of how many resources
you have it's still something I'll say
today
it's like 20 20 2012 Evan was was a
pretty smart guy you know he had some
information there but but the delivery
still needed uh a lot of work and so
this you know again I think a lot of you
are already still ahead in your delivery
over 2012 Evan and you definitely have
the information inside your head and so
it's how do we bring
uh more energy out Zan saying how would
the emotionally committed Evan say today
well this is it like look at look at the
look at the range that I'm using now
look at the energy into look at me
laughing at myself now this is I mean if
you've seen in my videos on stage or how
we even start Movie Makers there's a lot
more energy just go watch any of my
videos where especially the espresso
ones where I'm talking it's it's just
being able to tap into that emotional
range instead of just being trapped in
your logical brain because the content
is the same it's the wrapping around it
I said something that Zen like there
he's going ooh the content is not that
different but the packaging and how I
wrapped it
has changed dramatically which allows it
to hit people in a stronger way
um Denise said so I thought this was
pretty good I need new definition for
emotional delivery and impact yeah and
we're so worried about saying the right
words
you're so worried about getting the
perfect script it's like the script is
not the thing the emotional commitment
you have behind the words that you're
saying is the thing that will move the
needle for people
and so every time we try to learn a new
skill the emotional commitment will
probably drop down a bit every time we
give you a new structure to say hey like
try to start with a powerful opinion now
you're so stressed out it wasn't
powerful thing did it get the powerful
opinion right it might did that work or
not right and so it's okay to take a
little bit of a step back every time
we're trying to learn something new but
I want this to be something that that
you're constantly looking at to improve
your content in watching yourself back
to say how how emotionally committed was
I to that message that was I feeling it
more than was I worried about saying the
right words
today we are talking about Instagram and
uh the past the past year and a half I
guess I've had a love-hate relationship
with Instagram and and I'm gonna share
my new plan uh we just we just shifted
our entire Direction actually last week
uh and so this is very timely this
happened to be our our talk for today so
I'm gonna we're gonna dive in this is a
really important one instagram growing
and serving your community and I'm going
to talk about my plan which I've I've
not talked about again I just finalized
it with Nina last week and then how you
can win with content and win with
Community as well if you're taking
Instagram seriously this year
cool so here's one of the things that
has really been frustrating for the past
year and a half is that the reach is
down
organic reach on Instagram has been
dropping and I still love YouTube
YouTube is still my number one but I I
like having a number two for the short
form like where do you put your short
form content uh and there's Instagram
and Tick Tock and Twitter and Linkedin
and snap and all the other platforms uh
but the organic reach has been dropping
this is a quote from garyvee from two
years ago if you want to go you know
watch his video but Instagram's organic
reach is finished so just as we figured
it out it's over it's over now it's a
little bit uh maybe a little bit
hyperbolic but exaggerate a little bit I
wouldn't say it's over
um but it is harder to win compared to
before and everybody in my circle is
seeing their reach go down especially
over the past six months or so
so when that starts to happen it's like
okay am I doing something wrong am I on
the wrong platform how do I how do I fix
this so this is what's guided a lot of
my thinking especially the past six
months
the second is that growth is down and so
this is a comparison of Instagram to
tick tock for me
so it's May 2022 as we're recording this
this is my growth on Instagram versus
Tick Tock now Instagram I didn't really
take seriously until about 2019 so just
as garyvee is saying uh it's over it's
when I started taking it seriously and
that's where we had our biggest jump I
had an account back in 2016 but wasn't
really doing much with it and you can
see we had a big jump and it's been kind
of this slow upward growth
meanwhile Tick Tock has been growing for
us at an incredible rate with very
little effort and the effort I mean here
is that we're still posting a lot of
content there but Instagram has been my
number one for short form so it's been
YouTube Instagram
Tick Tock has been you know the past
year or so and in looking at the numbers
like holy cow we're getting so much more
incredible growth off of tick tock and
so I want to talk Tick Tock a little bit
today as well I'm not going to dive deep
into Tick Tock strategies that can be a
whole other session if you want to do it
but it's easier to grow and it's now
becoming a place for Education as well
so if you can see yeah I see the
difference so Mary saying geometric
progression with Tick Tock yeah the
other really cool thing about Tick Tock
that is that is uh interesting is
yesterday they just announced a revenue
share program so one of the main reasons
why YouTube has been so big for so long
is they share their revenue where the
other platforms really suck at sharing
Revenue so as of yesterday they launched
a new program it's coming out in June
and they're going to be given a 50 50
split a little worse than YouTube but
still decent off of ads that show up in
front of your content right now to
qualify you have to have over a hundred
thousand followers uh but that honestly
should be an achievable goal for you
guys
you know for what you want to do for the
people you want to serve for the message
you want to put out there to the world
you've got a big message and and we
should be aiming towards having a bigger
following it doesn't mean you have to
have 10 million followers to be able to
do it but a hundred thousand followers
is an achievable goal and it's likely
going to just go down as they expand the
program so once you can start making
money on it as well it makes it a lot
more appealing to a lot of people so my
plan
has now shifted as of May 2022 where
Tick Tock has become my number two so
YouTube is still by far number one it's
not even close but after YouTube it goes
Tick Tock for me and then Instagram
instead of flipping it the good news is
a lot of The Tick Tock strategies you
can apply to Instagram so a lot of the
short form content you can go to both so
what we used to be doing was taking our
Instagram content and then that becomes
our hub for short form and then that
goes everywhere so we'll make a tick
tock post we'll make a cartoon we'll
make a video we'll make a quote and then
that goes to tick tock and Linkedin and
Twitter and snap and all the other
places
so YouTube was long form Hub Instagram
was short form Hub and then whatever
goes to Instagram goes to the other
places
as of last week we're switching it it's
YouTube first still
Tick Tock as a secondary home and then
from Tick Tock we take the best
performing content and put it to the
other platforms
and so I want to start to at least gear
your mind towards it because a lot of
the strategies that apply for tick tock
for the content you can apply for
Instagram as well so just a shift this
has been a dramatic shift for me
um it's been coming you know it's been a
year and a half in the making especially
the past six months but this is now the
new plan for my content going forward
for anybody who's like oh my gosh I was
just learning Instagram I'm not going to
talk about Tick Tock and it's
overwhelming and like what am I supposed
to do you know this is part of the game
yeah and this is part of this is part of
my job with mover makers as well is to
show you not just what has worked but
what is working and what will work so
even the move from Facebook to Discord
might have been a little painful for
some people it's like I I gotta learn
Discord I've never used it before how
does this app work but this is part of
the game because people are not if
you're still using Facebook pages it's
it's a it's the dinosaur and it's dying
off versus Discord which is vibrant and
active and can be used to grow your
business and so in a similar way not
that not that Instagram is dying but but
good to know that this is the next thing
coming up and it's it's not just in the
future five years away it's right here
right now and so part of my job is to
help guide and push and move you to the
places where you can have the biggest
impact because that's what we're trying
to do right and so even something like
YouTube I'm not I'm not obsessed over
YouTube it just happens to be the best
place to get the message out and you
guys have a big message that people need
so let's talk about how to win with
content so when you hear me talk about
my strategy uh you might think oh is
Instagram dead
and and there's a lot of content people
saying is Instagram dead up there is not
dead you just have to shift
you just have to shift the type of
content that you're making to give
yourself the best chance of winning so
this was a really great I don't know if
you guys follow Adam Missouri or not but
he's the CEO of Twitter and he had a
post that he put out last year which was
really insightful as to where the
direction of Instagram is going and how
you can win so one of the big quotes
that he said was Instagram is no longer
a photo sharing app
where if you won on pictures
you're seeing a huge drop in engagement
especially the last six months
a lot of our our cartoons right saw a
huge drop in engagement in reach
Instagram is not promoting pictures as
much anymore oh Rebecca is drawing all
over my slides
we drawing Rebecca how do I don't even
know how to take that off but okay
Rebecca's adding some artwork we got
three green lines to our slides we love
you uh so I thought what I would do is
also even watch this video together
because there's a couple things in here
that I think would be
um really helpful to watch so if I load
up Adam's video here
there's a couple things I want to take
note start sharing more about what we're
currently working on internally at
Instagram just to give you a sense of
what's coming before it comes right so
again this is the CEO of Instagram
talking about what they're currently
working on and giving you a heads up
before it comes right so this was
how do we I don't know how to take this
off with Rebecca's three lines anyway
we'll figure that out
um before it comes so this is July sorry
end of June 2021. right now we are
trying to build new experiences
primarily in four areas the first is
creators and I've talked a lot about
creators and trying to help them make a
living and this has to do with the shift
in power from institutions to
individuals across Industries the second
is video video is driving an immense
amount of growth online from all the
major platforms right now and it's one
that I think we need to lean into more
and I'm gonna actually talk about that
more in a minute the third is shopping
now the pandemic shifted or accelerated
the shift of Commerce from offline
online by a number of years and we're
trying to lean into that trend and the
fourth is messaging how people connect
with their close friends has changed a
lot over the last five years or so and
has moved primarily to messaging away
from
what's interesting here he doesn't talk
a lot about messaging besides just one
point but he says people are moving
towards messaging and right here away
from feeds and stories
so we're gonna who's gonna go in about
video but Instagram one of the biggest
benefits of Instagram is a messaging
platform
the big advantage of Instagram versus a
tick tock is you can message people who
are not following you so a lot of
activity on Instagram is going down in
the DMS and we'll talk about a messaging
strategy later on today but
the theme of this was Instagram growth
and community that was the name of it
and so having a solid messaging strategy
is a great way for you to win build
connections build customers build
following Etc but it's interesting to
hear him say that a lot of people now on
Instagram are spending their time not
consuming away from the feed and the
stories and instead turn into messaging
feed and stories products but today I
actually want to talk a bit more about
video and I want to start by saying
we're no longer a photo share so that
was it like we're no longer a photo
sharing app and this got a lot of people
really upset it's got a lot of people
who built their brand off of Instagram
photos uh you see some of the comments
here
uh you know that sucks we love pictures
why won't Instagram work for having real
customer service uh Instagram is never
going to have what Tick Tock has in
terms of video algorithm Etc it's like
people are really upset
so Instagram is no longer a photo
sharing app so if you look at your
engagement I don't know if you've been
how long you've been on Instagram but
the engagement on your pictures and the
reach on your pictures versus the videos
has dropped dramatically
today exciting we're going to be doing
YouTube channel breakdowns and this came
up uh as a result of Lady Lexi who joins
me on my gaming live stream most nights
that I'm going live and uh she said look
at look at our channels do a breakdown
look at our channels and give us some
feedback we said okay we'll put it post
it as a topic and you guys voted it up
so we're going to be doing the first
part some Channel breakdowns what I
found is by looking at one person's
Channel you often get ideas on what you
can do for your own as well so hopefully
the examples we go through will be
helpful for you as well so I'm going to
start by pulling up lady Lexi's Channel
and get some feedback so you can get
some get your messages out to the world
make it an impact having a difference
and also hopefully making you some more
money as well so when I first look at a
channel and again this is something
hopefully all of we all of us can learn
from first thing we look at is our
banner and our Avatar here right so I
can see her face here cool this is
probably a little too much text and Lady
this is something that we've been uh
talking a lot about
trying to say say too much so what are
you all about right when I come and land
on this channel what are you all about
and so new show new show we don't have
to make the test promotional imagine
somebody doesn't know who you are so
we're not talking to people who already
know us we're talking to brand new
people so what do they need to know
about us I'm less concerned about the
time nobody really concerned consumes
YouTube videos by time nobody's real
like even my own videos nobody nobody's
like oh my gosh Evan you were five
minutes late on your video uh what
happened or you forgot the post
yesterday what happened people are not
we're not so important in people's lives
right where most people subscribe to a
couple hundred channels so they're not
really paying attention so the schedule
doesn't really matter
um so I wouldn't worry about most of
this a new show a new show would take
out weekly on Wednesday is a time
schedule I would take out and it's more
like what what are you all about what's
the value I'm gonna get from the channel
what am I going to learn how am I going
to improve myself what what am I going
to leave watching your videos feeling
and so that's the messaging that we want
to have on here I would change the
Avatar to be you
unless this becomes your character for
all the videos but it's not anywhere in
in your videos so I would make this you
and for most of you I got asked
yesterday in a presentation is it is it
better to do your company logo as your
brand or your face and almost always the
answer is faced because people connect
with people a lot more and they'll
connect with a logo
The Only Exception is if if you are a
bigger company or you have multiple
people on the team who are going to be
on the videos then there might be a case
for that but you guys are all individual
Brands like we're trying to build your
brand up not not for your ego and people
to you know say how amazing you are but
to serve and to help and you should be
instantly recognizable so this should be
your face lady Lexi
um and then even the title so if I look
at this combination what do we think
like if and you know some good comments
if you guys want to leave some comments
here if you were forget about the videos
if you just saw this Banner with the
background you know we got this water
this beach and then you saw the title
lady Lexi's life on the road what do you
what kind of channel do you think this
would be
I thought it was a travel Vlog says
Anita
in the chat if you were just to happen
on this
travelings is married travel says Andre
so we're getting a lot of travel
thoughts and uh that's probably what I
would think too to be honest right it's
like oh lady Lexi's life on the road
she's gonna be traveling she's gonna be
going places look at her on the beach
um which is not really what the channel
is all about or maybe it maybe it used
to be I don't know
um but
what is the story that you've been
through I mean on the on the gaming
stream when you've been joining in
um Brian says look there's too much
going on there Lydia says meditation
Joyce says traveling shocks as
meditation or yoga a lot of it has been
your healing Journey it's been about
speaking up it's been about finding the
right doctors to support you on your
journey right so what's the imagery that
supports that
uh the meditation is probably the
closest thing
to the journey is not so much about
travel and beaches Etc so I would
rethink that style behind you so that
people when they first land because
again we're not talking to our friends
and people who know us it's brand new
people who've never heard us before we
don't want them to think probably that
we are a travel vlog
now looking at the thumbnails I know
you've been doing a lot of work getting
the text uh shorter so I think some of
the older videos had a lot of text and
if we look down so if we look at you
know some of these for example right
you can't read that and I'm on my
computer now go to my phone and it's
going to be super tiny it's just
impossible to read impossible to see who
these people are and so good job on
doing the work to get it to something
like this where it is so much easier to
read than this
The Next Step would be to make the font
easier to read so
this font any fancy font is hard to read
especially small and you gotta imagine
people are scrolling through really
quickly through your videos just like
they're imagine you're walking through
an uh a grocery store aisle and they're
picking what cereal box that they're
going to pick the one that stands out
the most is the one they're gonna pick
so your videos might be showing up on
people's feeds but they're scrolling so
it has to stop them from scrolling and
make it instantly something that they
want to be able to click on and so
making the text legible and a good size
is important
uh so the sizing is a lot better now but
the font Choice makes it hard and the
color scheme makes it hard so all of
these stylized fonts should be used very
sparingly even all of this is is hard to
read
the stylized fonts are really hard to
read so what you want to do is use thick
chunky easy to read fonts that when
they're really small really stand out so
if you're looking at
uh yeah and the good news about YouTube
is you can go back and redo all these
things now you can go back and you can
update all of these videos as well you
can change the thumbnail uh Style on
them to make it stand out a little bit
more so there is a lot going on here I
would stick to a color scheme usually
we'd look at uh like a neutral color so
look like white black if you look at
mines like white black and gold
right you can potentially throw in a
second accent color if you want but
just that color scheme then makes it
easy to say hey that's an Evan Chronicle
video and that becomes the goals like I
want people to say that is a lady Lexi
video
uh next in terms of the pictures
generally bigger faces work so faces
work for sure
when it's just text it doesn't work as
well and when it's just a picture it
doesn't work as well so faces with text
works the best uh and again I need to be
able to see you from the phone so a lot
of these pictures are too small this one
is probably your best one where I can
clearly see you right I can see you
imagine I'm scrolling super quick
through the videos right if I'm
scrolling I don't know I mean even
looking at this on a computer I don't
know that this is you
these five pictures of Lady Lexi so I
would zoom in and make it something like
this as much as possible if you're
having two people then you can have them
side by side you can have them one on
each side obviously this is Terry way
Thompson fellow movement makers we love
you Terry
um all of this should be zoomed in more
so you could be you on the side
Terry on one side text in the middle or
both of you on one side and text on the
side
um the faces get a little bit smaller
when you're using two people on the
thumbnail but it could still be bigger
than what we've been using here so a lot
of this is just getting people to uh to
click
if I can't read the text and I can't see
the face I'm not likely to click and if
I am confused by what the channel is all
about right if I think it's a travel
Vlog then I'm probably not going to
watch the video uh as well next thing
for any video is the starting has to be
awesome you want you want to hook people
right away so step one is
just in terms of The Branding does this
person look like somebody who I want to
learn from right so do they look like me
it doesn't have to be back to Titan twin
content you don't have to look like
you're Oprah Winfrey but does it look
like you know what I've been through
and can you solve my problem
right so you know Alex in here doing his
salsa dancing this should be a salsa
dance at the top right it shouldn't just
be Alex's face it should be people's
salsa dancing if Zane's doing one around
confidence it should feel like I'm gonna
get more confidence just by looking at
the banner and the Avatar right so
that's step one like branding are you
the person that I think will help me
solve my problem step two is then with
your click-through rate having
thumbnails and titles that will get
people to want to click on the video and
then step three is keeping people in the
video so if you look at a video the
starting point has to be really powerful
so ladies fairly consistent right 10
hours ago 19 hours ago one day ago seven
days ago seven days ago seven days ago
nine days ago okay so the next for
scheduling for anybody here I would
space these out more instead of doing
three videos on one day take a week off
and then do three videos again on on
another day space these out so that
you're not squishing them all together
this would be better to have you know
six videos over seven days instead of
three videos in one day and then three
videos on another day and then have a
big break in between
the length is good 30 minutes 16 minutes
an hour 42 minutes 29 minutes 42 minutes
the length is good and then if we play
we can see how it starts
done with it I'm not going to do this
well that's when enough is enough it's
when you realize that your or
experiencing
mental or physical problems that
you get that pit in your stomach that
you know something needs to be done
and you are willing to go this is not
bad this isn't that bad the thing that
would change I mean we could get we
could be more
emotional it's like the first sentence
has to matter the fir you have to feel
it you're not just making a video you're
talking to somebody
but this is a lot better than than the
live streams where you're just kind of
welcoming people and having a good time
so this is a lot better and I would also
not lead with this never lead with a
static image go right to you
go or people talking right never lead
with just audio in a static image
because you want people to see your face
immediately you'll just lose people when
it's a static image
um but that one that part's getting a
lot better and then just more emotion
like imagine that this matters imagine
that your message is going to change
somebody's life today and try to
approach you with that
um not intensity but just intentionality
you know that somebody is gonna
somebody's in a really tough spot right
now they're going to watch your video
and they're going to only listen to the
first three sentences and the words that
you say matter but even more important
is the
emotion that you have in it
um so so this is great this is a great
start and then looks like you're moving
around and now you're outside and now
you have guests on board
um once you start getting data you can
pay attention to uh where the audience
retention is falling off like where are
you losing people you can look at your
data and see but but this is a fantastic
start
yeah I like it so the biggest thing for
you then is update update the banner
update the Avatar continue working on
the thumbnails to make the text super
easy to read zoom in on the faces and to
start your videos making them more
emotional and uh to the point if you
want to watch the full version of this
video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join